ok catch it by psychobabble here playing
saints row the [ __ ] that I can watch
as that's tennis at new game and you
know and um I'm more of a a more normal
guy
you
you
you
I can like that show
ready I like it saints row the third
references are just starting to rip it
up the story in a nester okay that's
time great leaders have risen her
probably getting stabbed dosha I could
get his lost ours and so so the ten
straight sense since clocking Stillwater
the one small town street gang has a
walls and to a media empire with Santa
movies and development jana gana and
Shonda are pop culture icons and here's
fun who the [ __ ] gives them that bears
the point is a Saints are on the world
stage in every criminal organization
once their crown
as I matter of time before one
hi
No
okay okay ya gotta get up he's super
ghetto yeah oh yeah huh
huh
that's Japanese commercials easiest
money in la paz grant Larson is right up
there you ready for this no worries I do
my own stunts hey you're just a
ride-along man so don't get all hong
kong style in there i got i am a method
actor if i'm gonna play a saint with any
degree of emotional truth i gotta make
it real thank God is this someone movies
huh trust me Burke it'll be real oh you
robbing a bank dressed like yourselves
oh yeah who doesn't want to be Johnny
get ultra post-modernism oh my god i'm
cool with the Saints movie but do we
really gotta drag this [ __ ] actor
around hey Josh some slack he's just
researching his part yeah I hope you
signed a waiver all right people nobody
died sorry jumpsuits line can we uh go
again you all know the drill he'll hit a
picture with the boss say sleaze get
mine [ __ ] hey don't be a dick Shirley's
up early bears bunch of [ __ ] we
should be all up in their [ __ ] like oh
sure there are gangs oh that's different
you got a plan and we just shootin all
these [ __ ] that is my plan
works for me Oh Johnny Gat Finnick
pretty goth fall Oh very missable go to
hell you wanna play [ __ ]
oh we're gonna die my own stunts hey hey
do these look like scripts to you all
right people what's fun night yeah get
this [ __ ] that's why you [ __ ] we're
coming for you ghetto Burke let's keep
moving I can't believe you still
thinking about Jason so that's a really
nice O'Connor's is the bulb it's fine
that get the hell out of here it's kind
of hot mmm huh normally to tell us don't
you [ __ ] shot oh that's my guys sorry
for the bullet in the face [ __ ] has
shut hey uh ok [ __ ] ok ok breathe no
way we're cracking this thing ready for
Plan B yep Josh come over here yeah
castles right here homes so uh what's
plan B huh drill it [ __ ] no we blow it
what do not cool man don't get to work
eyeshadow k will need to set those above
the vault hey I think you've got company
looks like they're coming in from the
lobby miss big birthday hey Josh Berg
don't be starstruck I'm very
approachable want me to sign your
browser the heads no that's all right
yeah
by night blade on DVD
is that better the actor actor some
chocolate look this baby are ya hey guys
call the helicopter found the way 20
football don't touch it uh all right
Josh are you trying to get us all jail
time what I don't want to be some dudes
finished we have to go after them forget
about it he'll be fine okay um how long
until the chopper gets here I don't know
I'll be like two waves of SWAT guys
think this bad boy here they come [ __ ]
[ __ ] left into
I thought you two really had something
there oh don't even go there hey the
same
let's get him and just taking a mile
and yeah I got that faces but they just
keep growing oh [ __ ] you can stop us hey
yeah let me just say that I ain't now
bet that [ __ ] I haven't if this much fun
in years
okay seriously who are these guys a
bunch of [ __ ]
yeah they look at a second chef
30
at this
uh there anything heavier okay oh [ __ ]
at a good thing I'd like a [ __ ] ton of
help here's not right
no very very sounds it pretty [ __ ]
bad ass
yeah what the hell they got safes
installed they like talking
you go out the back and you staying with
the ball
stay close early [ __ ]
gonna shut that thing down
so pimp receptor how far oh yeah yeah
you gotta grab that shift that gonna
[ __ ] it how are we still here got that
guy's got I'll hold off the cops can't
kill them all appreciate their country
nothing was an hour 10 softer baby yep i
will think is so dope
[ __ ] I gotta [ __ ] it genres on this damn
thing this case so dope he actually
beyond doubt TV for your fine yeah
where's that [ __ ] attack out there
chef
what the [ __ ] is going on here [ __ ]
what is that like checking ours oh [ __ ]
ok now this right oh no no no no no yet
that guy
am I ever
get this man hey dips out for her Amish